une intuition commune et que si on
libéralise complètement le marché de
l'information alors les informations qui
trient au fond de la concurrence seront
le fruit d'une intelligence collective
et mériteront l'attention qu'elles
auront reçu c'est ce qu'on pourrait
l'appeler l'hypothèse de l'efficience du
marché de l'information qui semble être
l'hypothèse sous-jacente au refus de
réguler l'information aujourd'hui je
vous propose de vivement questionner
cette intuition en appliquant la théorie
économique standard et en particulier on
se demandant si les conditions
d'application de cette théorie
économique standard s'applique
effectivement au marché de l'information
bien sûr notamment si vous suivez Eureka
vous n'êtes sans doute pas sans savoir
que cette théorie économique standard
est critiquée mais on va voir que même
si on accepte la théorie économique
standard il y a de quoi être très
critique de la libéralisation du marché
de l'information mais avant d'en arriver
là voici un bref rappel de la théorie
économique standard de l'efficience des
marchés celle-ci s'appuie sur certaines
conditions parmi lesquels on trouve un
atomicité savoir le fait que le nombre
de consommateurs d'intermédiaires et de
producteurs de l'information doit être
très grand et aucun agent ne doit voir
suffisamment de poids sur le marché pour
influencer directement notamment les
prix de la transparence de l'information
tous les participants du marché ont une
connaissance complète de tous les
facteurs significatifs du marché 3 la
rationalité des consommateurs un
consommateur consomme une information
avec un coût individuel pour consommer
cette information si et seulement si le
bonheur procuré par la consommation de
l'information surpasse ce coût
individuel 4 l'homogénéité des produits
dans l'industrie toutes les firmes livre
des produits que les acheteurs jugent
identiques homogènes ou substituables
autrement dit les biens échangé sont
semblables en qualité et en
caractéristiques et donc interchangeable
et 5 l'absence d'externalité la
production la diffusion et la
consommation d'une information n'affecte
que le producteur le diffuseur et le
consommateur de l'information et je vous
renvoie vers Wikipédia pour plus
d'informations sur tout cela sous ces
hypothèses et d'autres que je ne
détaille pas ici les marchés maximisent
alors le surplus social ce que beaucoup
reformule avec la conclusion déficience
des marchés autrement cette
interprétation les marchés permettent de
conduire à un état pseudo optimal de la
société
mal pour aujourd'hui la question que
j'ai envie de poser c'est est-ce que
tout ceci s'applique vraiment au marché
de l'information est-ce qu'un marché de
l'information complètement dérégulé
conduis vraiment à un état optimal de la
société et bien il suffit avec une seule
des hypothèses énoncées soit fausse pour
conclure que la théorie économique
standard ne s'applique pas au marché de
l'information mais comme on va le voir
il est en fait beaucoup d'hypothèses qui
ne s'applique pas du tout à ce marché et
ça ça revient non seulement à dire que
l'efficience d'un marché dérégulé de
l'information est très discutable mais
on va voir qu'on en vient même à
conclure qu'un tel marché est
probablement extrêmement dangereux et
comme on le verra en fin d'épisode
l'alternative bien sûr pas
nécessairement un contrôle centralisé de
toute l'information comme ça a lieu par
exemple dans certains pays autoritaires
à l'instar de la manière dont
l'information scientifique et produite
modérée et amplifiée il est tout à fait
possible d'envisager des alternatives ou
je ne vais pas vous la prendre le marché
de l'information moderne est composé de
certains très gros acteurs comme des
chaînes de télévision particulièrement
influentes des plateformes comme YouTube
Facebook ou Twitter beaucoup plus gros
que la concurrence ou encore des
intermédiaires pour la diffusion de la
publicité en situation de quasimonopole
je pense notamment à Google Adsense même
s'il y a aussi Facebook et qui forme un
cartel mais j'y reviendra en particulier
si demain YouTube décider de recommander
beaucoup plus les contenus très haineux
et radicaux ils auraient tout à coup une
influence monumentale sur le marché
d'information qui modifierait sans doute
l'offre faite par BFM TV ou le Figaro
est-ce que je viens de dire là et en
fait absolument pas spéculatif
mais le rôle disproportion de certains
acteurs dans le marché de l'information
ne s'arrête pas au diffuseurs classiques
certains individus uniques ont
aujourd'hui une influence
disproportionnée à tel point qu'on parle
aujourd'hui des influenceurs comme une
forme de métier ces influenceurs sont
capables de rallier un grand nombre
d'individus à leurs causes parfois des
millions de personnes en fait ces
influenceurs ont aujourd'hui une
influence telle qu'ils sont capables de
manipuler des grosses entreprises comme
par exemple les plateformes des réseaux
sociaux en particulier les Facebook five
une série de documents révélés par la
très courageuse et très méthodique
lanceuse d'alerte de facebook Frances
hargen c'est Facebook face montre que
facebook accorde secrètement des
privilèges au très gros influenceurs
comme on en a déjà parlé dans un épisode
précédent mais j'en profite quand même
pour le répéter il y a chez Facebook une
white liste de comptes Intouchables qui
inclut notamment les dictateurs
politiques de pays autoritaires Facebook
à sédicateur de violer l'atomicité du
marché d'information enfin un acteur
grandissant du marché de l'information
ce sont les campagnes de désinformation
dont j'ai parlé nous avons dans le
premier épisode de cette série pour
rappel chaque année Facebook combat ses
campagnes en retirant 6 milliards de
faux compte de ces plateformes
6 milliards de faucontre et beaucoup de
ces faux comptes sont possédés
indirectement par des entités uniques à
l'instar du Parti communiste chinois qui
possède 20 millions d'employés chargés
de produire de désinformation
[Musique]
20 million de Chinois un chinois sur 70
est payé pour désinformer et parmi ces
20 millions de Chinois 2 millions sont
payés à le faire à temps plein bref le
marché de l'information est loin d'être
un marché de concurrence parfaite ou
aucun acteur n'a un pouvoir de marché dû
à une influence disproportionnée et on
est en particulier très loin de l'idéal
démocratique où chaque individu peut
parler et être aussi écouter que son
prochain et rien que ça
devrait suffire à conclure que le marché
de l'information doit être régulé comme
c'est d'ailleurs le cas des médias
classiques en période électorale et
pourtant il s'agit là du plus faible des
arguments que je vais présenter
aujourd'hui et qui questionnent vivement
le capitalisme de l'information
ça fait un peu hashtag méthode que de
réfléchir à la transparence de
l'information dans le marché de
l'information mais c'est une question
importante est-ce qu'un consommateur
connaît l'ensemble de l'offre
informationnelle à laquelle il pourrait
avoir accès et s'il passe par un
intermédiaire comme la télévision Google
ou Twitter est-ce que le consommateur
sait pourquoi l'intermédiaire lui
recommande telle ou tel autre
information ce qui me semble gravissime
dans le cas du marché de l'information
c'est que la plupart des consommateurs
ont souvent une illusion de transparence
ah oui la télé parle de stèle scandale
parce que c'est le sujet le plus
important dont il faut être au courant
ou pire Twitter me montre ce tweet parce
que c'est ce dont tout le monde semble
parler ou encore pire encore YouTube me
dit de regarder cette vidéo car c'est ce
qu'il y a de mieux pour moi qu'il
s'agisse des médias classiques ou des
réseaux sociaux le choix de la
programmation ou les algorithmes qui
recommande à des milliards de
consommateurs le contenu qu'il devrait
consommer tout ça c'est extrêmement
opaque et très peu audité ou et
d'ailleurs vu que les algorithmes de
recommandation sont maintenant ultra
personnalisés leur audit révélera des
données sensibles ce qui posent des
problèmes dans le cadre de rgpd en fait
c'est même pire désormais chez Facebook
et Google puisque suite au Ligue des
Facebook five Facebook et au
démantèlement de l'équipe d'éthique du
côté de Google les données sensibles de
ces entreprises sont maintenant
inaccessibles pour la quasi-totalité des
employés de ces entreprises ce qui rend
même les audits internes impossible et
Google et Facebook semblent largement en
profiter et ce de manière aussi bien
immorale qui légale en effet les
révélations des Facebook five montre que
Google et Facebook auraient conclu
impact secret pour augmenter le prix de
la publicité pire le prix indiqué par
Google aux annonceurs et aux créateurs
de contenu de coïncide pas Google aurait
ainsi profiter de l'opacité de ses
données et de ses algorithmes pour
mentir à tout le monde pour récupérer la
différence ceci étant dit même si la
programmation des médias classiques et
les algorithmes de recommandations c'est
pas techniquement opaque pour la
quasi-totalité des acteurs le marché de
l'information est aujourd'hui beaucoup
trop complexe pour être transparent
après tout le fonctionnement du
journalisme est déjà extrêmement
complexe en tant que tel et les
algorithmes de recommandation repose
aujourd'hui sur l'état de l'art
d'intelligence artificielle est souvent
paramétré par des millions des milliards
voir des millions de milliards de
variables seuls des experts en
journalisme et en machine learning
pourrait partiellement auditer le marché
de l'information mais encore une fois
aujourd'hui ça leur est complètement
impossible vu l'opacité des médias et
des géants du web bref non seulement il
n'y a aujourd'hui absolument pas de
transparence du marché de l'information
mais il semble même essentiellement
impossible que ce marché devienne un
joueur suffisamment transparent pour la
quasi-totalité de ses acteurs et
pourtant la transparence c'est loin
d'être le plus gros des problèmes du
marché de l'information
une hypothèse fondamentale de
l'efficience du marché peut-être même la
plus fondamentale de toutes les
hypothèses c'est l'hypothèses selon
laquelle le consommateur choisi de
consommer si ça le rend plus heureux
mais du coup ça implique que plus le
consommateur consomme plus il est
heureux dans le cas du marché de
l'information ça ne semble pas du tout
être le cas au contraire au moins dans
certains cas disons dans le cas de cnews
ou BFM TV qui tourne en boucle en cas de
12 chroniques sur les réseaux sociaux
plus de consommation peut conduire en
fait à moins de bonheur à l'instar
d'autres produits addictifs dont les
effets secondaires sur la santé mentale
ne sont pas facilement identifiables par
les consommateurs c'est d'ailleurs la
thèse de l'excellent livre you are what
you read de Jodie Jackson selon qui la
consommation abusive de titre
sensationnaliste à scandale conduit à un
biais de négativité voire à de
l'impuissance apprise plus préoccupant
encore les troubles de santé mentale
suite à une overdose informationnelle et
en particulier à une overdose dans
certains types d'informations ces
troubles de santé mentale semblent être
parfaitement établi par des recherches
interne à Facebook mais selon les
Facebook five la plupart des découvertes
faites par Facebook et en particulier
autour de la dépression d'une bonne
proportion d'adolescente abusant
d'Instagram c'est découverte ont été
gardées secrètes par la direction de
Facebook et comme seul Facebook peut
mener de telles enquêtes les découvertes
sont impossibles à effectuer pour toute
personne extérieure à Facebook quoi
qu'il en soit il semble clair que
l'excès de consommation d'information
n'est pas toujours sain pour le
consommateur cependant les fournisseurs
d'information aujourd'hui sont moquent
complètement au contraire ils optimisent
aujourd'hui les algorithmes pour nous
rendre accro aux informations qui nous
livre qui t'a créé des addictions
néfastes sur client encore une fois il y
a pire
l'information n'est clairement pas un
bien homogène toutes les informations ne
se valent pas et toutes les
consommations d'information n'ont pas
les mêmes effets sur les consommateurs
certaines informations empirent l'état
épistémique des consommateurs notamment
les informations caricaturales
simplificatrices ou pleine d'excès de
confiance d'autres sont même toxiques et
dangereuses notamment quand il s'agit de
désinformation médicale d'incitation à
la haine raciale ou de cyber-harcèlement
malheureusement le marché de
l'information exploite cet hétérogénéité
de l'information et pas toujours à bonne
escient l'information sensationnaliste
populiste ou clivante et souvent
beaucoup plus apte à capter l'attention
du grand public et à ainsi être vendu
accompagné de publicité c'est ainsi que
le marché de l'information les
privilégie abondamment surtout quand il
est complètement dérégulé toujours selon
les Facebook five en 2018 Facebook a
modifié l'algorithme qui sélectionne
quel message affiché dans les files
d'actualité ce qui a conduit à une
explosion de la désinformation de la
polarisation et à des messages de haine
mais comme ceci augmentait le temps
d'utilisation de Facebook et donc la
capacité de Facebook à vendre des
publicités Facebook n'a pas remis en
cause le déploiement de son algorithme
mais ce n'est pas tout même quand il
s'agit de publicité l'information
aguicheuse est aussi moins cher à
diffuser pour le même budget vous pouvez
toucher un plus grand public on le
ciblant mieux et en lui montrant des
informations putaclic c'est d'ailleurs
cette vulnérabilité qui fut exploitée
par les agences de désinformation russe
des 2016 lors de l'élection
présidentielle américaine en effet une
enquête du Congrès américain a montré
que ses agences ont réussi à avoir
autant de visibilité que les campagnes
de Trump et de Clinton malgré une
dépense publicitaire 1000 fois moindre
pourquoi et comment et bien les agences
russes se sont appuyé sur des mêmes
extrêmement clivant ce qui a créé
beaucoup d'engagements et amener
Facebook à réduire le coût de diffusion
de ses publicités autrement dit sur
facebook plus votre information est
clivante moins Facebook vous fait payer
pour la diffuser notamment parce que les
clients de ses publicités vont alors
plus probablement c'est plus de temps à
consommer d'autres publicités sur le
site l'information néfaste est moins
cher à diffuser c'est un non-sens
éthique et là encore ce n'est pas tout
on a vu que la consommation est la
diffusion favorise le putaclic mais il y
a les mêmes incentives du côté de la
production aussi après tout le coût de
l'information varie aussi énormément en
fonction de l'information produite une
série de tweets clivant et
sensationnaliste coûte beaucoup moins
cher à produire qu'une vidéo
scientifique et qui croise un grand
nombre de sources et qui requiert en
fait souvent des décennies d'éducation
scientifiques pour être écrite tout ceci
conduit souvent au problème des Nutte
news qui a mon sens même plus
préoccupante encore que les fake news
typiquement les Facebook size qui ont
nécessité le sacrifice d'une véritable
héroïne frankless Haagen risque
désormais des années de prison c'est
Facebook phase qui ont aussi nécessité
le travail et l'expertise d'un très
grand nombre de journalistes voire de
chercheurs du domaine pour révéler des
manipulations immorales et illégales de
la direction de l'une des entreprises
les plus influentes du monde c'est sont
malheureusement mal connues ou mal
comprise du grand public et même du
monde académique pire encore des projets
mégalomaniaques comme passwords Google
sont essentiellement
ignorés par tous tant que le marché de
l'information restera très libre
malheureusement ce genre d'information
persistera à être noyé dans un océan
d'information alternative moins cher à
produire et à diffuser et parfois
produite pour noyer intentionnellement
des informations que les campagnes de
désinformation ne veulent pas voir
triompher ne pas réguler le marché de
l'information c'est être voué avoir ce
marché dominer et manipuler par les
campagnes de tes informations mais
encore une fois il y a pire
s'il y a un argument à retenir de cette
vidéo ce serait l'argument le plus
classique pour rejeter la dérégulation
totale d'un marché à savoir le problème
des externalités négatives l'analogie
avec les problèmes environnementaux est
ici très clair quand un producteur vente
un produit polluant à un consommateur
via un distributeur alors ces échanges
économiques ont un effet négatif sur des
milliards d'individus qui n'ont pas
profité de ces échanges et bien il en va
exactement de même de l'échange de
beaucoup de messages par exemple la
désinformation médicale à des effets
secondaires indésirables sur bien
d'autres individus que ceux qui ont
produit transmis et consommer cette
désinformation typiquement la
désinformation sur les vaccins conduit
des consommateurs de cette
désinformation à mettre en danger leurs
enfants et leurs parents mais ce n'est
pas tout c'est industrie doit
désinformation conduit aussi à devoir
prolonger des contraintes sanitaires
pour tous ce qui va ensuite augmenter la
précarité des étudiants et des petits
commerces et pour être ensuite conduire
à une profonde crise économique qui tu
aurais gravement des millions de
concitoyens autre exemple les appels à
la haine les producteurs les
intermédiaires et les consommateurs
profitent en un sens de tels contenus
informationsnel bon surtout les
producteurs et les intermédiaires qui en
profitent directement financièrement
cependant ces appels à la haine ont des
effets secondaires indésirables sur les
cibles de cette haine qui peuvent
ensuite être amenés à davantage subir
des violences physiques verbales ou
psychologiques pire encore ceci peut
conduire à des tensions géopolitiques
majeures à des guerres civiles voire
encore à des génocide or malheureusement
de tels exemples n'ont absolument rien
de théorique surtout dans un contexte
socio-économique post covid instable
comme on l'a déjà observé au miel en
Éthiopie mais aussi en Afghanistan au
Liban au Brésil en Inde en Ukraine ou
encore aux États-Unis et on peut
d'ailleurs être aussi inquiet pour la
France notamment à l'approche des
élections présidentielles enfin et comme
illustre si bien le film dans tout cas
une grave externalité négative de la
dérégulation de l'information c'est que
d'autres
Nathan ça va une intuition naïve selon
laquelle en vertu de la liberté
d'expression le marché de l'information
devrait être complètement libre
cependant la théorie économique standard
ne semble absolument pas capable de
défendre une telle intuition en fait la
quasi-totalité de ces hypothèses
fondamentales semble violer dans le
contexte du marché de l'information
voilà qui suggère que pour le bien
commun il est urgent et critique de
réguler adéquattement l'information et
en fait ce marché de l'information est
déjà très réglementé comme le montre par
exemple la loi du 29 juillet 1881 sur la
liberté de la presse la production la
diffusion est parfois la consommation de
certaines informations sont ainsi
aujourd'hui illégales notamment par
exemple quand il s'agit de
pédopornographie d'incitation à la
raciale de diffamation de violation
d'accord de non dévaluation de
révélation de données sensibles de
cyber-harcèlement ou encore Tarnac
financière d'ailleurs toujours selon les
Facebook five Facebook a commis des
actes qui sont passibles de peine pénale
très grave puisque
alors que les réseaux sociaux ont
aujourd'hui une influence probablement
beaucoup plus grande encore que les
plateformes financières puisqu'ils
influencent notamment l'évolution des
pandémies ainsi que les politiques de
superpuissance mondiale d'ailleurs en
tant que créateur de contenu moi-même je
tiens à m'excuser auprès des gens de
droite poétiquement pour le titre de
cette vidéo qui est très putaclic mais
qui nous correspond pas du tout au débat
actuel sur la régulation des réseaux
sociaux en effet aux US en tout cas il
semble y avoir un consensus entre
républicains et démocrate sur le fait
que le marché de l'information actuelle
va mal voir très mal et qu'il faut faire
quelque chose pour le réguler comme tous
les créateurs de contenu qui veulent
t'avoir un impact et des vues je suis
aujourd'hui complètement manipulé par
ces algorithmes de YouTube
parce que si je fais pas putaclic là ça
fait pas de ceci étant dit la régulation
avance et ce même aux États-Unis puisque
républicain et démocrate sont d'accord
pour beaucoup plus réguler le marché de
l'information et d'ailleurs en Chine
aussi le gouvernement veut davantage
régulier les réseaux sociaux mais je
suis pas sûr que ça soit très rassurant
oui parce que malheureusement bien
réguler l'information c'est avant tout
une tâche délicate il ne faut absolument
pas tomber dans une vision binaire
régulée ou pas réguler certains marchés
d'information comme celui en Chine ou
des régulations très dangereuses
d'autres comme le marché de publicité en
France ont des régulations qui sont en
fait aujourd'hui beaucoup trop légère
pour être appelé tel quel puisqu'elle
permet notamment la diffusion
d'information très trompeuse et très
dangereuse de façon tout à fait légale
et plus généralement c'est marcher la
publicité pousse des milliards de
consommateurs vers des habitudes parfois
très néfaste pour la société et pour
eux-mêmes comme acheter des gros SUV ou
consommer de la John food bref il me
semble urgent de réguler adéquattement
l'information à très grande échelle
c'est pour ça que je me méfie énormément
des alternatives à Facebook et Youtube
qui n'ont pas assez de station majeure
de régulation des contenus dangereux au
cœur de leurs produits et c'est aussi
pour ça que je n'ai vraiment pas été
tendre avec tipi en fait ce que
j'aimerais surtout c'est que beaucoup
plus de gens réfléchissent au faible
chantier de réguler adéquatement
l'information de manière satisfaisante
pour la plupart d'entre nous et ça
malheureusement c'est un chantier
extrêmement difficile et délicat
notamment parce que nous avons et nous
aurons inéluctablement des désaccords
profonds sur ce qu'est une information
fiable et plus encore sur la manière de
déterminer quelles informations doivent
être modérées et quelles informations
peuvent être amplifiées à grande échelle
en particulier sachant cela il me semble
que le futur de la régulation ne doit
pas être centralisé et sous le contrôle
d'un petit nombre d'individus justement
depuis plusieurs mois la plateforme
tournesol a été relancé après une
écriture complète du code et vise à
établir petit à petit une régulation
collaborative du marché de l'information
via notamment l'identification
collaborative des contenus d'utilité
publique mais pour cette régulation
collaborative devienne un jour crédible
il nous faut absolument d'abord montrer
qu'elle est prometteuse et pour cela on
a urgemment besoin de vos contributions
à notre plateforme si vous aussi vous
êtes convaincu que le marché de
l'information ne doit pas être laissé
déréguler et qu'il faut le réguler
adéquatement nous vous invitons à nous
aider en créer un compte sur tournesol
et en fournissant un tournesol des
comparaisons de vidéo dans l'espoir que
tout le monde soit finisse par avoir une
base de données suffisamment grande et
sécurisée pour devenir un standard de
l'éthique de l'information